Anyway, Adam, you ready? You know what
the topic is, right?
>> Hello.
>> Uh, what's your name? Hello.
>> Yeah. What? You know what the topic is,
right, Adam?
>> Yeah. I've been uh listening to you
talking to that guy.
>> Yes. And what are you?
>> I am a Muslim.
>> Oh, you're a stone kisser. Okay. So, you
know the topic is refuting with man's
lies about what the Bible says about the
Trinity, right?
>> Yeah. I thought you guys talking about
trinity, right?
>> Yes. So, you know, I'm refuting man's
lies who says the Bible doesn't teach a
trinity.
>> Who is Otman?
>> Doesn't matter. The issue is that one of
your D was using the Bible to show the
Bible doesn't teach a trinity. This is
what the topic is.
>> Yeah, I actually read the Bible too, but
I've never found the teachings of the
Trinity in it.
>> That's okay. Can I show you that?
>> No, I read the Bible. Do you want me to
show you that according to your Quran,
Jesus is the God of Muhammad?
>> Go ahead.
>> Okay. I mean, I'm going to use your
Quran, right? Because you just lied to
us. But it's okay. I understand. I'll
have mercy on you.
>> Where did I lie?
>> Because you just said you didn't see the
trinity.
Okay.
He is the first and the last, the
outward and inward. And he is knower of
all things. It's chapter 57:3.
How many first and last are there
according to Islam?
>> According to Islam, there is one.
>> Can your prophet or any prophet be
the first and the last?
>> No.
>> Okay. So here it is. He is the first and
last. So now you know the Bible agrees
that God is the first and the last. Let
me show you where it agrees. 48:12.
Okay,
let's see if you're honest or you going
to do I believe you're honest because
you fear Allah. Isaiah 48:12, "Hear me,
oh Jacob, even Israel whom I called. I
am he. I'm the first. I'm also last." So
the Quran and the Old Testament, the the
Torah of the Jews, say God is first and
last. Can a prophet say he's first and
last?
>> Can he say first and last? Probably not.
>> Can a prophet say that?
>> No. Can he cannot say that? Okay, good.
So now does the New Testament agree? Now
remember Quran said Allah is first last.
Old Testament says God is first last.
Now here's the New Testament. When I saw
him, I fell as like a dead man. He
places his hurried hand on me saying do
not fear. I'm the first and last. So you
see New Testament Christian books,
>> Old Testament books.
>> Yeah,
read this verse. Is this where you make
the point before you manifest? Let me
make the point.
>> Agree that God is the first and the
last. You just said no prophet can claim
that, right? So, do you agree
>> with the New Testament that God is the
first and last?
>> Yes. Yes, sir. God is the first and the
last.
>> You sure? Only God can be first and
last, right?
>> Only God can be first and last. Correct.
>> Dean because I want you to read
Revelation 117:18. You just buried your
dean. Read it for me.
>> And when I saw him, I fell at his feet
like a dead man, and he placed his right
hand on me, saying, "Do not fear. I am
the first and the last and the one um
and the living one and I was dead.
>> When did your Allah die?
>> Allah never die.
>> You just said it right there. You liar.
You just said Allah is the first and
last. And here he said I'm the first
last and I was dead. When did your
>> This is a revelation, right?
>> I don't care what it is. You said you
read the New Testament. You didn't see
the Trinity. I'm going to bury you if
you now change the subject. When did
your God die?
>> My God never dies.
>> But you just said only God can be first
and the last.
>> Correct.
>> But here the first last says I died.
>> But who said that?
>> The one who is the first and last.
That's who said it.
>> No. Who wrote uh the
>> I don't give a damn who wrote it. You
just said you just said I read the New
Testament. I didn't see the trinity.
Mut the revelation is part of the Bible.
So, do you not admit you're a liar, son
of Mutah, because the Bible has Jesus
claiming to be God?
>> Did you not just say
>> that I read the Bible and the Trinity is
not in the Bible?
>> Yes.
>> Did you not say that? Okay. Is
Revelation in the Bible?
>> When I Yeah, true. It's in the Bible,
but when I read the Bible, I read Mark,
Luke, Matthew, and John.
>> Adam, I don't give a damn about that
argument. We're not arguing if the Bible
is accurate. We are arguing what you
said. The Bible doesn't teach the
trinity.
>> Correct.
>> You just admit revelations in the Bible.
Whether you think it's corrupt or not,
do you admit this book of the Bible? It
is Jesus who just said, "I'm the first
and last and I was dead."
>> Correct. That's that's Paul saying that
Jesus said
>> it's John. Paul didn't write this and
it's Jesus talking to John. But coming
back,
>> John was dreaming, right? He was in a
dream.
>> And did your prophet also dream? And did
your prophet say that dreams is a part
of wahi and
>> two?
>> Yeah, true. That says it in for prophet.
>> You want me to send you to Mecca to lick
the black stone cuz you're changing the
subject. Let's see if you can behave
yourself and control yourself better
than your prophet.
>> Yes, sir. I'm trying to be nice and
respectful.
>> No, you're not being nice because you
began with a lie. Stop changing the
subject. I'm gonna get you out of here.
Focus on what you said. You said the
Bible does not teach a trinity.
Revelations in the Bible. Jesus claimed
to be the first last, which you said
only God can. When I bury you, oh yeah,
but revelation is a dream. I don't care.
I want to deal with the first argument.
Do you
>> the Bible, whether it's true or not, has
Jesus claiming to be God by claiming to
be the first and last?
>> If he said it, yes, that's true. Okay.
What I'm saying this is a dream of John.
John is not a prophet. It's just a
dream. This is
>> in his dream in chapter 37 of your
Quran. Was it in a dream that Ibraim was
told to sacrifice his son?
>> Uhhuh. True.
>> So stop telling me dream God in dreams.
>> Buddy, if you talk over, I'm going to
send you to kiss the black stone.
>> Stop telling me dream because your Quran
says your God speaks in dreams. and in
visions. And your prophet said dreams
are part of revelation. So even if it's
a dream, it's still revelation. Stop
changing the subject.
>> I am not changing the subject. The
dreams are revelation when it cames to
prophets, not to John.
>> No, that's not what Bkari said. Muhammad
is saying even after when he dies and
he's burning that dreams that you have
are still revelation.
>> Show me that.
>> Oh, if I show you then I'm going to send
you to the black stone. Hold on. I'm
gonna, you know, I'm going to show you.
I'm get you out of here because you're
you are an umi. You don't know.
[laughter]
>> Here you go.
There you go.
>> Do you know that there is a prophet uh
in the Bible that kissed the black stone
too?
>> Did you know that the black stone became
black and is going to come with eyes and
tongue to intercede for you because you
are pagans? And I know you're still
>> pagan too, right?
>> Isaiah. No,
>> you are. Isaiah bu shows that Muhammad
is because Isaiah didn't kiss a black
stone. It is a call from the altar mut.
>> Okay. So, stop changing the subject. Do
you want me to show you that dreams are
part of revelation?
>> Go ahead.
>> Okay. Can you shut up for once and stop
changing the topic so I don't have to
jump with you?
>> No, I'm not. I'm just answering you when
you said.
So if I bring up Isaiah 6 and I show you
that was a coal from the altar in heaven
and he didn't kiss it because it was the
seraraphim that brought the coal and put
it on his mouth. He didn't lick it like
your prophet used to lick it like
chicken.
>> No, he say
he just kissed it like Isaiah did. They
both did the same thing.
>> If I show you he didn't kiss it and lick
it like your prophet licked Aisha. Are
you going to say I'm a stupid kafir and
son of mutah? All right. This is again
what Andrew Wilson said. This is what
happens when you marry first cousins.
All right.
This is what happens when
see right here
chapters on dreams. Andrew Wilson won
the debate. You're right, Andrew. This
is this is what happens from inbreeding.
You see, I can't focus because I'm
stupid. Because my first cousin Mary,
his second cousin, and then my second
cousin's child married her nephew and
then they had me. This is the result of
inbreeding.
All right, here you go. Let me just go
through here. Abu Hur narrated that the
messenger said, "When time draws near,
the dreams of a believer will hardly
ever fail to come true and the most
truthful of them in dreams will be the
trust in speech among them." Why? The
dream of a Muslim is a portion among the
46 portions of the prophethood. You
dumbass. He's talking about dreams that
you will have after your prophet. And
you see, so dreams are still considered
part of revelation. So you see, but he
had a dream. Yeah. But your prophets,
the revelation came to him in a dream at
first according to Aisha when Jesus
scraped semen off of him. And according
to chapter 37 of the Quran, Allah
revealed to Abraham in a dream who to
sacrifice. You see these pagans,
they have to lie to you because they
can't be consistent.
Do you know that Isaiah he licked the
black throne? No, I don't know what
Isaiah you're talking about. It's not
Isaiah the Bible.
This is the result of inbreeding, guys.
And you're telling me this old Sam can't
show up once in a while. You try to keep
them on topic. Dude, you said Bible
doesn't see Trinity. When you show the
son of Mutah, it does. Oh, but your
Bible, you know who your Bible? I don't
know who wrote Bible. I don't know who
you know revelation come from Paul. Paul
here Revelation.
Yeah, man.
But revelation here revelation
revelation. What they hear from Paul
from Paul
and you're wondering why I treat these
pagans the way I do. You can't even have
a conversation. Can't stay on point.
You brought up the Bible doesn't
trinity. I bury you alurations.